- What's up everybody,
its ya boy Zack Evans.
I'm here at Buzzfeed
and I'm gonna make my
co-workers rap battle again.
Part deuce.
Mr. Ned Fulmer in the house.
- Hey, what is happening?
- Ashley Perez is calling
you out to rap battle.
- I don't know if I can rap battle Ashley.
- Well you're gonna have to.
- Can I pee first?
- You can.
- Oh my God, I should get my
hoodie on like Eminem would do.
- This is how its gonna go.
You get ten points for flow.
You get negative one points
for every time you cuss.
There's been a lot of rap beef lately.
We're gonna change that today.
This is all about
complimenting each other.
So, one point for a
compliment about just like,
their physical features.
One point for compliment
about their character.
And one point describing
why they are a good friend.
- I was, I'm not gonna lie,
I was writing like
messed up raps about Ned
before I knew this was gonna happen
and now I gotta switch it around.
- Here we go, Ashley, hey girl.
I like your hair, girl.
And don't mistake me for blindness
cause I think you have a lot of kindness.
You are such a good friend to me,
you watch out and let me go pee pee,
this battle's over, get a life.
My name is Ned and I love my wife.
I love rapping about
kindness, its so much easier.
- Hey, hey got a guy with me,
and he's nice and he's kind,
he's fly, you see.
His name is Ned and he's got a wifey.
Ned in the house gettin' hifey.
Dang, Ned you really nice.
I like your hair, your
face, your style, your swag.
Oh Ned, what you got in that bag?
It's your laptop cause
you're so organized.
Damn, Ned. Damn, Ned.
His favorite color's red.
- Now you need to thug it
out for the rest of the day.
Deuces.
Yo, my boy Ryan B.
You ready to do this?
- Yeah, let's do it, man.
- Alright, who you
gettin', who you gettin'?
- I'm gonna get J Tan.
You ready to rap battle?
Your candy ass gonna sit
in that chair all day.
- Oh yeah, this is my beat right here.
Uh, check it out this is Ryan B,
he's a decent MC kinda like me.
He's all like, physically fit.
After doin' three months of that crossfit.
And he can kinda like, rap a little bit.
Yeah, he's kinda the, uh.
(laughing)
- Yeah. Justin looking good today.
Damn, look at your face like no way.
Hair lookin' fresh, my God.
I don't know what to do, my dog.
(laughing)
- You just lost to the Justin Tan.
How do you feel?
- Not good.
- Chris Reinacher, are you ready to battle
Quinta Brunson?
- Are you ready to be my Mekhi Phifer?
- Ho ho ho.
- That's how ready I am.
I read the comments of the last rap battle
and I know that it was pretty unanimous
that I won and you were a close second.
- Based on your lie, that's fine.
I will still trash you.
Aye, aye Chris I like that shirt
and it makes me hurt
because you're rhymin',
and you're flowing, and
you're making these videos.
Everytime I see you I'm like,
hey, Chris, yo.
You're such a good friend,
one I can depend on.
With your great hair and your great stare
and your brown eyes and that wide smile,
I wanna stay for awhile and
spend some time with Chris.
Chris, don't diss just be my friend
and I love you.
- Oh, I'mma murder that rhyme.
Uh. Uh. Yo, ya eyebrows on fleek.
Your hair is bitchin'.
I love Quinta because inside, she listens.
And she tells you the truth and shit.
Man, I like to take photobooth and stuff.
I forgot, I shouldn't cuss.
But I'm gonna do it. You like my cousin,
you like family. You're
like a mother to me,
you're like a brother to me.
I feel like I'm stuttering.
But I continue.
I like your shirt, its a Buzzfeed thing
it was free, bezerk.
- Someone call 911 right now because
- Friendship fire.
- Friendship fire, y'all.
- [All three] Friendship fire.
- What, what.
- Tell me in the comments
who you think won
this compliment rap battle.
And we'll see you next time.
Deuces.
- Your mom gave birth
to you, in which case,
she's great.
- Your whole family is blessed
to be in the presence of you all the time.
- Do you wanna know what they say?
Wow, Chris is really good.
I hope he gives me a note on my
comical videos so they can be better.
Oh.